das schweizer olympische freeski team
hat auf ihrem instagram account mehrere
unterhaltsamer eindrücke aus pjöngjang
veröffentlicht man kann unter anderem
fabian bösch dabei beobachten wir auf
eine recht eigenwillige art eine
rolltreppe nutzt er selbst kommentierte
die aktion mit den worten nach 20 jahren
habe ich immer noch nicht kapiert wie
das ding funktioniert mache ich das
richtig auch das video von der imitation
der bobfahrer durch die skifahrer wurde
bereits zum internet hit das olympische
komitee könnte also nach so viel
zuspruch vielleicht mal darüber
nachdenken die winterolympiade um ein
paar neue sportarten sowie diese zu
erweitern